camille n'en revient pas celui qui est
resté maire de la commune de 50 à la
motte lacroix au bailli pendant près de
trois décennies est un peu choqué par sa
dernière mésaventure il voulait obtenir
une procuration pour son fils mais pour
cela il lui fallait une carte d'identité
en cours de validité
il a réclamé son renouvellement avant
d'apprendre que la longueur du nom de sa
commune posait problème je voulais pour
mon deuxième fils une occurrence ion et
que je téléphone à la mairie de
saint-quentin pauvres pour je connais
bien absolument une quinzaine de jours
après coup de téléphone à nadine je
m'accorde m'excuse mais
59 la croisée aux moyennes ne passe pas
sur les cartes d'identité vous savez on
se rend pas compte at qu'une carte
d'identité surtout maintenant son cas
fort manque pas mais c'est indispensable
et ça vous bloque beaucoup de choses il
voulait pas et camille n'est pas le seul
à connaître ce type de péripéties dans
le village un des habitants de notre
commune s'est d'abord adressé à nous
pour obtenir une carte 10 nautiques
qu'il ne possédait pas et nous ne sommes
pas centre notre commune des spas
centres de traitement des dossiers de
demande de carte d'identité il faut
s'adresser à la commune 2 d'à côté qui
s'appelle eu un des plus petits noms
français ont eu seulement deux
caractères il n'avait toujours pas de
nouvelles il est donc retourné voir les
services et on lui a appris à ce moment
là qu'ils ne pouvaient bénéficier d'une
carte d'identité au nouveau format parce
que le nom de notre commune comporte
trop de caractère 38 caractère ce nom
qui existe depuis l'an 800 regroupe
trois lieux dits le raccourcir serait un
réel crève coeur pour les habitants en
france plus de 40 communes sont
confrontées à cette amputation
administrative